we did it yatta destiny first 290
million oh boy
tea service was right behind us but we
did it oh man it took us a nice very
nice thank you everyone
I can't believe everything is just
changing so quickly you have all these
news articles Priya is it called
preemptively preemptively
yeah preemptively celebrating the fact
that tea's serious has passed us but oh
no no I think it's important to know
that unless we have a common goal this
is just gonna go on forever
and I think we've proven ourselves that
we're more than capable of doing just
that okay but if we don't have a common
goal then we're just gonna look like a
bunch of idiots we're never good this is
just gonna go on forever which it easily
can by the way which is fine but we're
more than that we have more integrity
than that we're not don't care okay it's
first to 100 million and then we will
let t-series passes you will have my
permission to pass after we hit a
hundred million I will write full a step
aside I will graciously step aside and
let you pass these theories leave your
entry pros
why using the Drake format using the new
Marzia format because Marzia memes get
more uploads imputes me what i can do
funny faces guys please
they were thirty thousand ahead I don't
know how he did it
I don't understand at least where
actions anymore just don't forget about
me when I lose to t series that's all I
guess well it's not gonna happen it's
not losing if we let him win
okay ten year challenge fortnight diet
in ten months but minecraft never died
in ten years I am so proud of this
community yeah for some reason now it's
like a meme to uh neurotically play play
minecraft it used to be oh you play
minecraft oh that's awesome - oh you
play minecraft only kids play minecraft
oh you play minecraft that gave us dead
- you play minecraft thank you hit a
brofist bro hit a freaking fat brofist
self-driving cars more likely to hit
wild deer oh my god please the story
writes itself
Felix we need explanation clown poor
listen we don't know the source we don't
know who posted this and we don't know
why this was made so therefore we will
ignore this news moving a hug at 100
million we're deleting the channel we
don't know the source of this this when
we hit 50 million I added a little
Easter egg at the very end saying yeah
I'm deleting the channel at a hundred
million so haters better start
subscribing okay violent videos mods
closing down this sub young children
they big shoutouts to the to the mods I
appreciate that they they acted quickly
to prevent that I think they did a great
job and I really appreciate it Japanese
reinforcements are available pukes one
day I would like to very much
take a collaboration video with pity son
Kizuna ie
for me review
if the game is so relevant why haven't
the headphones changed ah oh my god this
is so embarrassing yeah our minds I
thought the game was relevant they told
me listen they told me Felix the game is
so relevant and I'm like this is awesome
I'll tell everyone how relevant the game
is I felt so disappointed
while I made pewds what an amazing guy
next me Thank You Shane
very cool he said something I appreciate
a lot in his video today almost nights a
thing that I did mention in that video
is that I said that I watched him back
in the day but I like Shane a lot more
now because he seems like he's more
honest and open with himself and I think
that's the thing with YouTube that I
really like so
keep going Shane you're doing great it
works i screen recorded and uploaded a
video with a song Oh hit books so
there's this theory that it's not a
theory but this is mean that to fight if
you don't know the name of a song just
upload it to YouTube because they have
all this advanced technology to claim
the video it's so it will say what song
it is because they will get claim well
if you upload it and someone did it
hi dragon boy yo the Content ID claim ur
is time is on my side
claimed by um G I think I heard
somewhere the reason why you can't sing
happy birthday on
is that the one sing happy birthday and
it will cost you
turns out the pablor song is under
copyright performers are supposed to pay
do not you're not allowed to sing it
happy birthday to you
at restaurants because it's not licensed
just to give you a taste of how bad then
in my opinion the music industry is with
with protecting the artists it is
certain no integrity involved with
sharing something that you created I
don't get this idea but it's literally
the same thing here on YouTube even if I
hum a song that's enough for a video to
get claimed entirely
I can't wait for article 13 I really
hope I'm just imagining things
Oh God break out on forehead bags under
eyes substance abuse I think feelings
needs a vacation to the records he looks
so drink concern nine-year-old I
appreciate the concern it's been a rough
couple days it's time for the big guns
pewds happy wheels fortnight minecraft
roblox cool man I really got to play
happy wheels I don't know if I can do it
man
her he's probably thinking about other
women him I wonder if there is someone
who is subscribed to prettify
submissions but isn't subscribed to
PewDiePie you know here you are hit that
subscribe button when God created
feelings good looks that's right
thanks right a girlfriend that's right I
do have a girlfriend number one most
subscribe YouTube channel
legs oops dog for those of you hasn't
missed who has missed the breaking news
that's right in order to defeat t-series
I have revealed that I have very large
tongue as I will show you now
[Music]
the war is still odd well clear ah it
hits zero again oh god it zero again one
ahead fast
ah this is why I hate video games it
appeals to male fantasy oh my god I have
Leahey finally a video game where I can
live my fantasy teaser is so but caught
alive holy crap
whoa whoa what what what happened there
they gained 25,000 out of nowhere
Oh 31% off G fuel pay 69 percent of the
price oh my god guys leak the case you
didn't know you get 16 you can pay 69
percent of the full price of G fuel
it's the biggest sale they've ever had
if you enter the code PewDiePie number
five trending for gaming in India hey we
did it guys
we settled for number five now
apparently what the hell is this fan out
of the original nine year olds and yes
the guy in the back is sigh they made
sigh look like a total boy everybody
everybody gay as all face that's a great
name you like your lose meme reviews bad
camera quality Brad one few news book
reviews 35 and that's how it's done
everybody all men
have a mental age of nine you know
you're not 9 but in there you're 9 we
are all we are all silly oh my god he
gets it
wow that's nothing here just a scream
subscore no sub subs I thought it was
gonna say subscribe subscribe to judy by
pew you laugh you win his entire fanbase
wait that's silly sometimes you just got
to pull some strings to makes things
happen I made a skin for Peter pine for
night took three hours couldn't find a
face that looks like him but I hope he
likes it damn see I saw these on Twitter
but I didn't know what it was from
that's really cool I'm pretty sure the
only thing to save for night from a
famous legend is to add this skin I
won't just remember March 18 as a day my
twin daughters were born but also the
day pivot I became the first title to
surpass 90 million subscribers
congratulations of your twins man that's
incredible
thank you guys so much for all the
support honestly it means so much to me
if you want support the channel just
it's there and that's it for me for now
see you guys tomorrow
why brofist at a hundred million
brofist that 100-minute tuber simulator
it's now so relevant that it's got a
brand new minigame crania drop the crane
and get fresh items only available in
the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys legs